Yeah, I feel definitely there are a lot of hard times....
...especially being in the bubble, you sort of overthink a lot of things.
But I think I just got through it because during quarantine,...
...I wanted to, you know, set myself up to possibly win this tournament.
I felt I just worked so hard I wanted to give myself an opportunity...
...and I wanted more people to see more names.
Yeah, I mean, I was thinking about all the times I've watched the great players...
...sort of collapse onto the ground and looked up in the sky...
...and I've always  wanted to see what they saw and for me, you know,...
...it was really an incredible moment and you know, I'm really glad I did it.
Yeah, I did think about wearing a mask during the trophy ceremony.
But they said not to wear a mask so I just did what they told me to do.
Yeah, I guess I'll celebrate this win just by, I guess, by processing it more.
I think the last few times I wasn't able to process it.
And I'm just surrounded by my team, people that I like, love.
Yeah, I feel like the more, hopefully, the more times I win grand slams,...
...I'll be able to, you know, celebrate better.